the media cheer covered authoritarianism
while ignoring the science
hollywood sneers at non-leftist and los
angeles decides to let crime flourish
i'm ben shapiro this is the ben shapiro
show
[Music]
today's show is sponsored by expressvpn
your online activity shouldn't be public
protect yourself at expressvpn.com
ben we'll get to all the news in just
one moment first you could be saving
hundreds of dollars on your cell phone
bill you're spending way too much
on that cell phone bill right now did
you know your family could save over 800
a year just by switching to pure talk
from verizon or at t or t-mobile
think about it what could you be doing
with that extra 800 bucks
and you don't have to sacrifice coverage
puretalk has the same coverage same bars
one of the big carriers they charge you
half the price you're not going to
sacrifice customer service either
because their team is based right here
in the united states there's some of the
nicest people you will talk to get
unlimited talk texts and two gigs of
data for just 20 bucks a month you don't
need
the unlimited data that's how they get
you if you go over on data usage pure
talk usa is not going to charge you for
it so what exactly
do you have to lose except for all the
money that you are spending on the bills
comes back into your pocket grab your
mobile phone dial pound 250
say ben shapiro when you do we'll save
50 off your first month dial pound two
five zero say keyword ben shapiro see
here's the thing when you talk with the
phone company and you ask them what
you're paying for very often they
obscure
what exactly you are paying for not so
with pure talk usa get that unlimited
talk text two gigs of data same coverage
as one of the big mobile companies
puretalk it's simply smarter wireless
style pound 250
say keyword ben shapiro again i'll pound
two five zero say keyword ben shapiro
let's get 50
off your first month the covid wave that
is engulfing the country
continues unabated we have not seen
hospitals overrun generally
in the united states yet uh we are
starting to see
obviously capacity being strained
particularly in rural areas that don't
have a lot of open icu beds
in big urban areas we're not starting to
see that quite yet one of the big
problems right now is we don't have a
lot of flex capacity what we mean by
that
is you can't shift resources from rural
areas to urban areas the way that we did
early on in the pandemic because
the wave is hitting pretty much
everywhere all at once if you look at
each state chart
every state is now seeing increases in
coveted cases
increases in hospitalizations increases
in icu beds being taken up
and we are expected to see that for at
least the next week minimum thanks to
thanksgiving presumably that will also
happen after christmas public health
authorities are telling people they
ought to stay home
not because it is necessarily dangerous
to travel in and of itself
but if you have covid and you go
somewhere else in the country you could
be seating a new pocket of kovid
in that place and right now obviously it
could be asymptomatic
while traveling okay with all of that
said and all the usual provisos
be careful be reasonable socially
distance make sure that you're not
in direct contact with people who have
pre-existing conditions at least in
close proximity to those people if you
are in close proximity to virtually
anybody
out of fear that you would spread this
thing to others and they will spread it
to somebody who's vulnerable you should
mask up if you are in close proximity
with people right these are all the
reasonable measures that we have been
told
four months none of that has changed the
glee with which our authoritarian
legislators and and governors
and mayors the glee with which they are
shutting down society
is truly something to behold it's really
amazing because
they're sneering at us they really are
they're sneering at us
they believe that they are the
reasonable ones they are the rational
ones and therefore they are capable of
making their own risk reward
calculations seeing andrew cuomo in new
york
just a couple of weeks ago was saying
that he was going to have a gathering
for thanksgiving including his 89 year
old mother
and his two daughters who are in their
20s right which
is the definition of an
intergenerational gathering
and meanwhile he was telling everybody
else they need to shut down and not
travel for thanksgiving he had the mayor
of austin
who was literally telling people from
his timeshare in cabo
not to travel you've seen eric garcetti
who's out there protesting with people
during the black lives matter protests
without a mask
now telling everybody that they need to
shut down their outdoor restaurants uh
at the exact same time that he is
telling hollywood that they can go ahead
and continue filming and they can
continue doing their catering services
in food tents directly outside of their
shoots
right the hypocrisy from our from our
leftist authoritarian leaders
is astonishing and their
self-congratulatory hypocrisy is really
the most galling part
because it is not that they are doing
this in sadness it is not that they are
doing this
with a level of regret listen we have no
other choice we've tried everything else
and this just isn't working
and so in order to protect our medical
capacity we're going to have to use
well-calibrated policies to shut down
the possibility of spread
like that i think we would all
understand i mean seriously
i think that if you have a major spike
in a particular area and you're running
up against hospital capacity
then there may be a necessity for
suggesting for example you have to limit
indoor dining to a certain percentage of
full capacity or that you only do
outdoor dining
there there are times when you're going
to have to use these sorts of measures i
mean even sweden
which was sort of the case model of a
country that had not fully shut down
even sweden
is now backing off and starting to throw
in the towel on this particular subject
according to allah pundit writing for
hot air the
the swedish government is now backing
off of its own
procedures here before they had
basically suggested that they were going
to
you know continue to to allow everything
to remain open
and that herd immunity would eventually
be reached it turns out statistically
speaking it just really didn't happen
instead they started to see spikes again
just like the surrounding countries and
so they have now engaged in some of the
same lockdown procedures
that some of the other countries around
them had engaged in okay so you have to
follow the data and you have to follow
the policies where it leads but
at the very least we should be assured
that our politicians are not excited
about limiting our freedom that they are
not excited about limiting our liberty
and that if they believe that freedom
and liberty ought to be limited it ought
to be limited for them
as well and yet the policy is not well
calibrated
and our politicians are patting
themselves on the back their arm it's
like mrs incredible
in the in the incredibles the arm has
lengthened it's physically lengthened so
they can pat themselves on the back for
what a wondrous job they are doing
even as people die and even if they blew
it in the first place and the most
obvious example of this is of course
andrew cuomo who wrote an entire book
about his leadership during the crisis
he did a uh he did a presser yesterday
and he uh
called in anthony fauci again i have not
been
critical of fauci throughout this
pandemic i think that he's been doing
the best that he can as a general rule
he didn't get it all right he said early
on he shouldn't wear masks then he
reversed himself he suggested early on
that schools should be closed then he
reversed himself
but he's been doing the best that he can
my problem with fouchy is his
willingness to become a sort of popular
figure of of worship that part is
ridiculous
right the fact that you was posing for
the cover of in touch magazine and that
he was throwing out first pitches at
washington nationals baseball games and
and this kind of stuff like that is not
appropriate for a public health
counselor
and for somebody who is doing a public
service job
the whole point of public service is not
the plaudits it is not the accolades it
is to serve the public
it is not to be posing on the cover of
magazines telling us what we all ought
to do the most popular doctor in america
this kind of stuff
okay so he and uh and cuomo had a bout
of self-congratulation
this is really more on cuomo but this is
this is just absurdity piled on top of
absurdity while cuomo is calling for
mass shutdowns across his own state and
across the country and while he's
evading responsibility
for his own failures he suggested that
he and fauci
are just like the modern day robert de
niro and al pacino
maybe in righteous kill here right here
is andrew cuomo
maybe we enlist you i'll do it with you
we'll do an ad
telling new yorkers it's safe to take
the vaccine
to uh to you know put us together we're
like the
modern-day uh de niro and pacino you can
be which whenever
whichever you want you can be the de
niro or pacino
and cuomo i'll give you a fun boy who do
you want to be de niro or pacino
which one do you want to remember i love
them
i don't want to insult one or the other
if i say one i don't want to hurt the
feelings
the politician that guy's a schmuck
andrew cuomo schmucktastic that guy
what a putts i mean seriously like the
fact that he's sitting there he said
over 30 000 people die in a state
and he's seeing spikes again in his
state he's saying am i al pacino or am i
robert de niro if i tell people to take
the vaccine they'll take the vaccine
if i tell people to mask up they'll mask
up i mean that guy has enjoyed flexing
his power more than anybody in america
with the possible exception of gavin
newsom
out in california and the media have
continued to portray him as some sort of
great
popular hero andrew cuomo and it's it's
ridiculous
by the way he happens to be an absolute
jerk apparently yesterday a former
andrew cuomo advisor put out a tweet
thread talking about what a jerk he was
her name is lindsey boylan she said her
most toxic team environment was working
for governor andrew
and then she put out like a 13 tweet
threat she said i've had many jobs
waitressing at friendlies as a teenager
was an infinitely more respectful
environment even when i had bad
customers who tipped for me
if people weren't deathly afraid of him
they'd be saying the same thing and
you'd already
know the stories again this is a former
andrew cuomo staffer but don't worry the
media treats him as though he is just
a wonderful wonderful man and again all
of this really comes down to we have a
class of people in this country who
believe that they are better than you
they believe they know more than you and
they believe that they have to
paternalistically guide you through life
another example of this there's a piece
in the new york times today
by a woman named elizabeth rosenthal
she is a doctor uh she uh worked as an
emergency room physician before becoming
a journalist
she's the author of a book called an
american sickness how health care became
big business
so her piece today in the new york times
is titled it's time to scare people
about covet
you see you're a fool and so she has to
scare you about covid now nowhere in
this piece
does she actually cite data nowhere
because if you knew the data
then you might be able to make a
rational risk reward calculation instead
her idea is that we have to scare the
living hell out of people about culverts
they make absolutely
non-rational decisions about the own
their own level of risk
so here's what she writes in the new
york times and again this is the the
general perspective
that so many elitists in our society
have the rules don't apply to them but
they do apply to you
and they have to scare you because
you're an emotional creature and because
you haven't been following the rules
you're the person who's been violating
all the rules and so we have to scare
you now here's what she says
i still remember exactly where i was
sitting decades ago during the short
film shown in class for a few painful
minutes we watched a woman talking
mechanically rasply through a hole in
her throat
pausing occasionally to gasp for air the
public service message this is what can
happen if you smoke
i had nightmares about that ad which
today would most likely be tagged with a
trigger warning or deemed unsuitable for
children but it was supremely effective
i never started smoking in doubt that
few
if any of my horrified classmates did
either when the government required
television and radio stations to give 75
million dollars in free air time for
anti-smoking ads between 1967 and 1970
smoking rates plummeted since then
numerous smoking scare campaigns have
proved successful
some even featured celebrities like joel
brenner's posthumous offering with a
warning after he died from lung cancer
now that i'm gone don't smoke whatever
you do just don't smoke as the united
states faces out of control spikes from
coven 19 with people refusing to take
recommended even often mandated
precautions
our public health announcements from
governments medical groups and
healthcare companies
feel lame compared to the urgency of the
moment a mix of clever catchphrases
scientific information and calls
specific duty they are virtuous
and profoundly dull instead it's time to
focus on some sharp terrifying realism
fear appeals can be very effective says
j van bevel associate professor of
psychology at nyu
i'm not talking fear-mongering but
showing in a straightforward and graphic
way what can happen with the virus
from what i could find the state of
california came close to showing the
urgency
a soft focused video of a person on a
ventilator featuring the sound of a
breathing machine but not a face it
exhorted people to wear a mask for their
friends
moms and grandpas but maybe we need a
psa featuring someone actually on events
later in the hospital
you might see that person bucking the
vent bodies naturally rebel against the
machine forcing pressurized oxygen into
the lungs which is why patients are
typically sedated
another message could feature a patient
lying in an icu battery mobile tubes in
the groin with a mask delivering 100
oxygen over the mouth of no mouth and
nose eyes wide with fear
watching the saturation numbers rise and
dip on the monitor over the bed
these psas might sound harsh but they
might overcome our natural denial
okay here's the thing nowhere nowhere in
this piece does she actually talk
about the rates of death from kovid for
particular populations this
is my great criticism it's been my
criticism since the beginning you have
not been given data
you have been given opinion instead
you've been given
large numbers like how many people have
died or how many cases there are
generally in the country
you have not been given the striated
data explaining what your risk
factors are or the risk factors of
people around you so you can make a
rational decision
everybody understands it is possible to
die of covid the question is
what sort of daily activities are you
going to rule out in order to prevent
somebody from dying of covid and what is
your risk or their risk of dying of
covid
this is how you make rational decisions
okay the the
basic idea from our betters is that
they're going to scare us into
compliance
with ridiculously authoritarian health
dictats
and when you compare this to lung cancer
and smoking commercials
recognize that smoking is a voluntary
activity
okay and that not smoking is something
that the vast majority of people do
but not going to the grocery store not
going to hang out with friends
not going out into public areas for a
walk without a mask which is
apparently what they're now telling you
in la you're not allowed to do right
that stuff is the stuff of everyday life
we're not talking about smoking an
optional activity you may or may not
enjoy
we are talking about what is your risk
factor if you let your five-year-old go
to school
and yet these jokers are telling us that
the best way to get people to comply
with dictates of non-rational behavior
is to scare the hell out of you and then
they wonder why we don't trust them
if you are openly saying that your job
is to scare me into complying with
health measures that are not calibrated
to succeed then
you know what you're the bad guy you're
the bad guy and there's a reason that
people are not trusting
the experts here because the experts
have been completely inconsistent
because the rational risk reward
calculation has been thrown completely
out the window
in favor of policies that make no sense
at all
right admiral brett gerard who's the
assistant secretary for health and human
services
he was pointing out yesterday they were
seeing cities around the country now
starting to be on outdoor dining he said
there's literally no data to support the
idea
that we should be banning outdoor dining
it doesn't matter apparently you
shouldn't dine outdoors unless you work
in hollywood in which case you can
totally dine outdoors and also
the best way to make people comply with
this nonsense is to scare the living
hell out of them even
if they are 20 and healthy and this is
why whenever you see these stories and
you saw these stories from the media
repeatedly
teacher dies of covenant 19 and then you
find out halfway down through the story
the teacher was never in school and
acquired it
at some other event or you see these
stories
ridiculous stories about outbreaks on
college campuses and then they never
tell you how many kids have actually
died of this on college campuses
the answer best as i can tell is close
to zero
and they never tell you this stuff
instead it's all scare tactics and then
when people say well i'm not sure that
you should be that scared
you can make a rational calculation they
say that you're taking covert lightly
okay people are not going to obey
ridiculous
insane regulations that make no sense
here's admiral brett pointing out that
all these places shutting down outdoor
dining are doing so not on the basis of
science they're doing so on the basis of
political incentivization
political incentives right now for
author for our authoritarian leaders
is that if you lock down you get all
sorts of credit and if you don't lock
down you get all sorts of blame and it
doesn't matter what the outcome is
what really breaks my heart is that i
don't know of any data that says you
need to shut down
outdoor dining or outdoor bars we really
wanted to limit
the indoor crowded places the evidence
clearly
does not support limitations on things
like outdoor dining
particularly that are spaced outdoor
bars
you know the evidence just isn't there
and remember shutting down completely
um particularly if you don't have
evidence can be counterproductive
it can be counterproductive as we'll see
in a second experts are saying that it
can be counterproductive but don't worry
your media experts who are certainly
acting outside the purview of their
expertise
are telling you that you must lock down
forever odd infant item and if you don't
agree this is because you're a kova
denier which is insane
we'll get to more of this in just one
second first let's talk about encrypting
your data so the fact is there are
people out there they want your data
they either want to monetize it or they
want to just hack you and take your
credit card information for example if
that's ever happened to you it is an
absolute nightmare well this is why i
use expressvpn to stay
safe and secure online it's hard to know
whether your device or network is
vulnerable to hacking
if you ever use wi-fi at a hotel or a
shopping mall you're sending data over
an open network meaning no encryption at
all
the best way to ensure all of your data
is encrypted and can't be read by
hackers
is to use expressvpn just download the
expressvpn app on your computer or
smartphone you tap one button you can
secure 100 of your network data
and then just use the internet the way
you normally would expressvpn is
incredibly reliable it's the fastest vpn
service i've tried they're also rated
the world's number one vpn provider by
review sites like techradar and cnet so
if you want the best in online security
and privacy protection head on over to
expressvpn.com
bennett is super easy to install with
one click you are protected
your gram your grandparents can protect
themselves with expressvpn it really is
that simple expressvpn.com
pen you get three extra months free with
a one year package again protect your
internet with the vpn i trust
expressvpn.com that's expressvpn.com
ben okay so again our moral bettors keep
telling us
that we ought to listen to them but the
problem is that they are probably
getting regulations that make
absolutely no sense and then if you take
account
of countervailing concerns like for
example the health effect
of a completely destroyed economy
or the economic effect of shutting
people's businesses down then they tell
you you're taking this thing too lightly
so we're back where we were in march and
april
where if you said listen if we're gonna
formulate policy we should look at
trade-offs here
then people said he wanted to kill
grandma we are right back there okay it
doesn't matter that the data now show
that people can act safely and securely
so long as they act reasonably
instead we are supposed to simply fall
for the same propaganda that we were
pushed
in in march and april and that is why
you're not seeing
in the establishment media any
interviews with business owners
right business owners who are being put
out of business you're seeing it on
shows like this one
you're seeing it on shows on fox news
you're hanging on talk radio you're not
hearing it anywhere on cnn or msnbc
the business concerns instead what you
hear is the business owners who want to
open up
are bad people here's a minnesota bar
owner who happens to be a woman of color
speaking on fox news about how the
governor of minnesota is now shutting
everything down
a governor cannot shut down businesses
at a whim
he cannot pick and choose who's going to
be a winner who's essential and who's
not essential because that's basically
what he did
he said that we are not essentials all
americans are essential to me and
for him to pick and say that my business
is not essential and that we have to
shut down i have two businesses i have a
gymnastics gym and a restaurant
and i have to shut down both businesses
because these things were not essential
and for me i'm not going to back down
to tyranny okay and again this is what
it feels like right now is are you going
to back down to tyranny
by agreeing with health officials who
are promulgating regulations that are
not
reasonable in the extreme and agreeing
with the media that is willing to
misinform you all the time
dr monica gandhi told yahoo news he's an
infectious disease specialist at uc san
francisco
it's not because the public is
irresponsible it's because they are
losing trust in public health officials
who put out arbitrary restrictions we
are failing in our public health
messaging
she says there's a better way to engage
in all of this she says a harm reduction
approach would be to encourage masking
and social distancing instead of
demanding that people have no contact at
all with friends or family they don't
live with
in other words even during a pandemic
absence only is not effective
but you are seeing public officials take
the just say no approach because there's
only political benefit in just say no
that way if somebody does something
wrong you can always tell them that they
broke your rules
right that way you can never be blamed
only the people can be only the little
people
can be blamed after all you said don't
do it ever don't go out of your house
stay in a bubble don't open your
business make everybody unemployed
and the politicians get to sit there and
they get to benefit and they get to
smile and talk about how they're like
robert de niro and al pacino when
politicians enjoy
their authoritarians their
authoritarianism this much uh it is
demonstrative
of a serious problem in american life do
you think this is the last time they're
going to try to use this sort of
authority
yeah i was a skeptic of this at the very
beginning there are a lot of people
friends family of mine who are saying
you know this sort of power grab
we're uncomfortable with it because
we're afraid that it could become
something permanent i said well listen
there's a global pandemic on we don't
know all the facts
as the facts come out these regulations
will be relaxed
the american people won't stand for it
and then it became clear that a lot of
americans would stand for it and
in fact many americans will call for it
and so the question becomes
what now is the bar going to be for
mayors and governors to declare an
emergency and simply use
all of the authority they have accrued
to themselves to do whatever it is that
they want okay
this is dangerous dangerous stuff yes
individual liberty is at stake when you
are not
relating rational policy in any way to
the risks
that are currently out there and this is
exacerbated by the fact that the media
are utterly inconsistent
there's only one consistent message from
the media and that is the message of the
left it's certainly not the message of
truth or the message of objective fact
and the media are wildly inaccurate
about everything they cover with regard
to this pandemic and then they blame you
for not believing them perfect example
of their misinformation today
so the media started repeating and
featuring
a a woman named rebecca jones on tv
last night and she was on a i believe
she was on cnn
a bunch of stories printed about her she
was
originally a low-level worker in the
covet data center for florida and the
reason that she was fired originally she
said that she was a whistleblower
and that she was trying to reveal data
in florida that governor ron desantis
was trying to cover up
and as it turns out that was just a lie
right this is going back to
to i believe like
may in the middle of may she was fired
okay so
they claimed that she was the architect
of florida's covet-19 dashboard and that
she had tried to reveal data and that
florida had fired her for for
attempting to reveal that data that is
not true
okay so she actually was asked to manipu
she said she was asked to manipulate
data to support
rhonda sansa's plan to reopen florida
instead
she was asked to temporarily disable the
ability to export data from the
dashboard so it could be verified that
the data
me the data matched other sources she
originally was actually fired
because she was fired first
insubordination according to the
desantis administration rebecca jones
exhibited a repeated course of
insubordination during her time with the
department
including unilateral decisions to modify
the department's coven-19 dashboard
without input or approval from the
epidemiological team or her supervisors
the blatant disrespect for professionals
who were working around the clock
to provide the important information for
the covid 19 website was harmful
to the team okay so she was fired for
performance issues okay the reason she's
back in the headlines is because now
she's out on twitter
claiming that the actual reason that she
was fired
is is not just because she was revealing
data and she was a whistleblower but now
she's claiming that ron desantis
authorized the police to raid her house
right that all of her technology was
seized at gunpoint by the authorities in
florida because ron desantis
is engaged in some sort of fascist
takeover there's only one problem not a
word of that story is true
the media are running with it anyway
because they don't care about what is
true and what is false all they care
about is their narrative
which is that governors who want to
remain open are bad and governors who
are out there
who are authoritarians are good because
in the end they want those
authoritarians to control you not to
control them
to control you we're gonna get to the
actual story here
in just one second because the media are
not telling you the truth broadly
broadly read
we'll get to that in just one second
first let's talk about the fact that um
it is very important to own a firearm
okay safety and security very important
to me i own two firearms but you got to
know how to use them and
you have to make sure that you have the
legal protection in case god forbid you
actually have to fire a gun
in self-defense more and more
law-abiding americans are purchasing
guns and making that choice to protect
themselves and their families if you're
a gun owner you have to be aware of
self-defense laws where you live
it's just not responsible to own a
firearm and not know the legal
ramifications of using it you need that
proper education
you need industry-leaning training and
you need the legal help of god for bid
you have to use it this is why
the uscca has purchased an insurance
policy that provides the association and
its members with self-defense liability
insurance
you need the us concealed carry
association at the uscca get started
today by texting gun to 87
222 you'll receive the complete
concealed carry and family defense guide
for free
in this guide you will learn how to
detect attackers before they see you how
to survive a mass shooting
seven firearms drills that could save
your life and much much more
it's a 164-page guide loaded with
valuable information
in addition if you text today you'll be
entered to win a thousand dollars to put
toward a gun of your choice so you can
use it
to protect your family text gun gun into
87 222 right now
again text gun to 87 222 and joined up
with my friends over at the uscca
so as i've been saying there's this
story out in the media that rebecca
jones the supposed data scientist over
in florida
she had her house raided at ron desantis
behest it turns out that that is just an
absolute falsehood the actual story the
actual story
is that according to the florida
department of health someone hacked into
a system
used to send emergency communications
earlier this month and sends an
unauthorized message
to members of the state emergency
response team responsible for
coordinating public health and medical
response
the november 10th message obtained by
the tampa bay times urged recipients to
quote speak up before another 17 000 are
dead you know this is wrong you don't
have to be a part of this be a hero
speak out before it's too late
so who exactly hacked into the system
then sent an unauthorized message
apparently according to a court warrant
it was this
it came from the isp address of rebecca
jones's house
so the reason that she was actually
arrested is because she hacked into a
public information system
that she did not work for that is why
she was arrested that is why her house
was raided it was not because ronda
sansa was trying to shut up the
whistleblower
okay but it doesn't matter the media are
just going to lie to you and they're
going to continue to lie to you
and the media are going to continue to
promulgate insane double standards
so some of the media double standards
include you are a very very bad person
you
are a very bad person if you choose to
go out in public
even if you're wearing a mask even if
you're socially distancing the fact that
you have not
holed up in your house until the vaccine
is available
and maybe beyond this means that you are
a bad person
not only that if you're a member of
particular religious communities you're
a particularly bad person so if you're a
jew in new york
and you're attending a minion even if
it's a socially distance minion you then
a group of 10 men praying together then
this means that you are a bad person you
are responsible
for the covet surge however if there are
surges in minority communities that's
due to systemic american racism
but we are seeing the same narrative now
promulgated with regard to vaccination
so there have been polls done and what
they show is that a huge percentage of
americans are
quite unfortunately skeptical of taking
the coronavirus vaccine
now i'm not skeptical of it i will be
happy to take it right here on air if it
makes people feel any better
i do not care i'm very much in favor of
vaccinations this thing
will be vetted all the way down to the
ground by the time that it is released
to people who are of my age range it has
already been vetted as already going out
in the uk in fact it is a blight on the
fda
that a medicine that was a vaccine that
was developed in the united states by an
american company pfizer
is going out in the uk before it's going
out in the united states it just
demonstrates the crappiness of our
bureaucracy
but beyond that there are a huge
percentage of americans who are
skeptical about about the vaccine
and that's not just the usual sort of
skeptical about about the vaccine crowd
this includes a huge percentage of
people who are skeptical about this
particular vaccine
for a wide variety of reasons some from
the right because they have some sort of
conspiracy theory about
the profitability of the vaccine i've
been hearing weird rumors about how
falcio and stock and this or that
that's not how vaccines get developed
we're not rolling out a vaccine to make
anthony fau rich that's a bunch of
nonsense
and then on the left you hear i don't
trust the vaccine specifically because
it was developed under president trump
that one came directly from kamala
harris which is completely crazy
okay but what the media have said is
that the the refusal to get a
vaccination
it is blameworthy if you are of a
particular group and if you are of a
different
particular group then it is not
blameworthy so if you're a white person
and you are skeptical about the vaccine
this is because you're an anti-vaxxer if
however you're black and you're
skeptical about getting the vaccine this
is because of america's long history of
systemic racism
there's a long piece in the washington
post today called amid history of
mistreatment
doctors struggle to sell black americans
on coronavirus vaccine
so you're not seeing any of this sort of
moral opprobrium attached to black
americans who don't want to get the
vaccine that you are seeing to a huge
number of other americans who don't want
to get the vaccine
what is the rationale because the
history of health care in the united
states
is intertwined with racism says the
washington post
fewer than half of black americans say
they will get the coveted vaccine
which is wild considering that covet is
disproportionately affecting black
americans it is actually
more important for black americans to
get the cover vaccine than nearly any
other racial group in america 63 of
hispanics and 61
of white people say they will get it
many black people say they do not trust
the medical establishment because of
glaring inequities in modern day care
and historical examples
of mistreatment this deep-seated
skepticism has led to a burst of
confidence-building efforts across the
country
some led by the nation's top black
doctors and scientists and funded by the
us government
so far the response has been mixed at
best with many black americans like
those
in in certain black congregations saying
they want more information or cannot
count on the federal government
to work in their best interest and one
of the reasons that they are skeptical
is because they are are thinking back to
the tuskegee the infamous tuskegee study
that was done in the 1930s in which
federal health officials conducted
secret experiments on black men to study
the progression of syphilis obviously an
act of official evil
from the united states government at the
time okay but that also happened in the
1930s
okay it is now last i checked 2020 and
the the very notion that we are supposed
to act as though it is legitimate
for more legitimate for black americans
to refuse a vaccine because they're
worried about systemic american racism
in 2020 thanks to stuff
that was evil that was done in the 1930s
like the the double standard here is
again pretty wild
so if you're an american of any race who
wants to open a business
the media don't want anything to do with
you you're bad
you don't care about other people if you
don't want to get the vaccine because
you're skeptical generally
you're bad and the media don't want
anything to do with you if however
you're a black person who doesn't want
to get the vaccine then we have
long pieces about how it is perfectly
reasonable for you not to want to get
the vaccine because back in the 1930s
the american government was racist
okay you wonder why people don't trust
the public health officials or the media
who are supposed to be disseminating
information because there's always an
agenda there is always
an agenda and that agenda is is being
propagandized by people in hollywood
again it's it's elitist in the media
and in hollywood and in government who
believe they ought to rule your lives
and decide what is morally okay and what
is morally not
and this is how you end up with the
specter of pete davidson on nsl
snl on saturday night live telling
people over the weekend that if you're
protesting lockdown you look like a baby
i'm noticing that pete davidson was
sitting on the set of saturday night
live
like a foot and a half from from another
human being while he was saying this
i saw uh the protest people were outside
the bar shouting about freedom
taunting the cops chanting that they
should arrest the governor but it's
staten island so i assume that it was
just like a typical last call
and are you against these protests i
mean kind of but i'm also just happy i'm
no longer the first thing people think
of when they say what's the worst thing
about staten island
i take it that you found these protests
frustrating yeah man they're making us
look like babies
you know you know it's bad when even
people in boston are like ah
drink it home your queers um
okay uh first of all i'm still not sure
why people find pete davidson humorous
but
beyond that pete davidson is sitting at
his workplace
a foot and a half from another person
wearing a mask right a foot and a half
from another person wearing a mask but
he gets to lecture you about what you
ought to do and
his business i've noticed is not being
destroyed also you may have noticed
there's a live studio audience for snl
you know how
because they actually designated i'm not
kidding they actually designated
live studio audiences employees for
purposes of essential services
for snl okay so it only applies to the
little people it only applies to little
people like you
you own a business you want to spend
time with your family the rules must be
applied to you and you are a bad person
if you buck the rules or if you protest
the level of arrogance that is applied
to one half of the american population
is just insane it's
just insane and you'll be ripped up and
down by the way
if you note this so matthew mcconaughey
committed this grave sin
so mcconaughey uh happens to be he is on
the left last i checked
he's a democrat i know that he's in
favor of gun control he spoke in march
for our lives
but he happens to be sort of more
culturally moderate and so he was on a
show with with russell brand
and he said the far left in hollywood is
arrogant toward conservatives and the
world just caved in on him how dare he
say this
because there is one thing that the left
cannot stand and that is someone calling
out their bull crap here is matthew
mcconaughey calling out their bull crap
and getting a bunch of crap for it
there is a lot on that ill liberal left
that absolutely condescend patronizer
arrogant towards
that other 50 you and you say hey we
want to get out
with the vote we want people to go be
able to go vote we're going to do a
campaign to let people vote
i'm like 100 yes everyone is there
anyone who would say no to that
and then they can't help themselves at
the very end of it they go
so we don't let those criminals get back
you're like no don't say the last part
you lost 50 of your audience
okay mcconaughey got a bunch of crap
from people in hollywood for this how
dare he
because how dare he point out that
there's an entire other side to the
political aisle
this is the kind of scorn that hollywood
has for you this is kind of scoring the
media have for you and your politicians
right this this group of elitists who
all traffic in the same circles
these people believe they ought to rule
you from above and if you buck that
system in any way
regardless of the industry that you are
in then you will be called out
and you will be ostracized you'll be
socially ostracized
and you get some more of that in just
one second because you know it does feel
in the united states and it has felt for
quite a while i'm firmly convinced that
this is what the trump backlash has been
about
i'm firmly convinced that it feels if
you are on one side of the political
aisle which is to say anywhere
to the right of karl marx at this point
but certainly anywhere to the right of
hillary clinton
that you are under constant assault
you're under constant assault from
authoritarian government officials
from a media that will lie to you and
about you you're under assault from
hollywood
that wishes to promulgate messages that
run directly counter to your values
you're under assault from social media
that censors your viewpoints
and from journalists who will go digging
through all of your old posts to find
something that they can
use as a club to cuddle you you're under
assault from corporations
and from your bosses who might fire you
if a bad old tweet is resurfaced
it feels like that it feels like the
walls are closing in and that is not a
coincidence
there is a plan from elitist to make the
walls close in on you
because they must they must achieve your
silence and they must achieve
not just your silence but your ascent
they want you to be complicit
in the destruction of your own values
that is the goal here
and that is why it feels monolithic
that's why it feels like a tsunami right
now a cultural
cultural tsunami and trump was a middle
finger to that that middle finger is not
going to go away post-election
regardless of what happens regardless of
how this election ends up being
adjudicated
regardless of what the electoral college
does okay that that
push to take over all of the
institutions of power in our society
from government
to hollywood to academia to the
education system
to to them to all of the main outlets of
media to social media
that push is going to continue unabated
from the left because they're engaged in
renormalization of american values
they're engaged in institutional capture
so they can cram down on you a
particular agenda and then ostracize you
if you dare to speak up against it we'll
get some more of this in just one second
first let's talk for a second about a
fantastic christmas or hanukkah gift so
jewelry right that is my go-to so i need
to get my wife something for hanukkah
this year
jewelry is always the go-to but you're
gonna spend too much
okay except if you go to the best place
for jewelry that i know i am talking
about
the pearl source at the pearl source you
get the highest quality pearl jewelry at
up to 70
off retail prices why because pearl
source cuts out the middle man by
eliminating traditional five times
markups by jewelry stores and selling
directly to you the consumer you can
shop safely and securely from the
comfort of your home
at the pearl source you'll find the
largest selection of pearls available
anywhere
each jewelry piece is custom made for
you you can customize your jewelry based
on pearl size quality gold type length
many more choices the holidays are fast
approaching shipping carriers have an
unprecedented amount of volume
don't wait the perl source offers fast
and free two-day shipping on every order
with zero contact
delivery everything comes beautifully
packaged in an elegant jewelry box so
it's ready to be given
as a gift not sure if she'll love the
gift no worries the pearl source comes
the no hassle 60 day money back
guarantee so it is risk free i've gotten
a couple of beautiful pieces from the
pearl source for my wife
a beautiful string of pearls as well as
some pearl and gold earrings don't
overpay for your jewelry go to the pearl
source today buy beautiful jewelry at a
fraction of retail prices for a limited
time listeners to the show
can take 20 off the entire order for the
holidays go to thepearlsource.com
enter promo code bennett checkout for 20
off your entire order again that's
thepearlsource.com enter promo code ben
and check out the people i trust i know
the owners of the company it is a
fantastic great company go check them
out right now
the pearlsource.com enter promo code ben
at checkout and again take twenty
percent off your entire order all right
we're gonna get to more
of the cultural scorn that is now being
ladled on to you
if you are of a particular uh if you're
of a particular ilk
but first let me tell you about
something you may have noticed some
changes have been made
you notice this right here this is our
new
improved leftist tears tumbler it's like
better than the old one
it's better because you can see it's
shinier it's got these stripes the
bottom and at the top
it even has your little leftist here on
the back this thing is it has the dw
logo on the top i mean this thing
is better than the old one by leaps and
bounds this is snazzy stuff
now if you're not already a daily wear
member you should join right now not
just because you get a brand new
awesome tumblr but also because we have
a lot more stuff coming
just around the corner the michael moles
show is now five days a week
adding more content for our members to
enjoy or ignore as the case may be we
are also adding the entire prageru
catalog to dailywire.com by the end of
the year we've already uploaded all of
the prageru five minute videos
the candace owens show from prageru
michael moles book club and the rest of
the library is being added as we speak
earlier next year candace is joining the
daily wire here in nashville she'll be
launching a brand new daily wire show
in front of a live studio audience we
are also launching our first feature
film under daily wire's upcoming
entertainment channel i could not be
more excited to announce
what that's going to be to you it's a
real film i mean it's good stuff
we are also building a new investigative
journalism team to replace
the legacy media cartel so we are
fighting against the establishment media
that has been misinforming you for years
and twisting the narrative and
castigating you as evil join the fight
seriously it's not just that you get
better content you also get to join the
fight when you subscribe so go on over
to dailywire.com and check it out also
if you have not ordered our daily wire
christmas tree ornaments yet you have
until tomorrow december 9th
to get them in time to decorate your
tree yes time is running out
that would be all of the daily wire
house plus god king jeremy boring as
santa's adorable elves including me
the most adorable of all orthodox jewish
shelves made out of painted
metal i mean i gotta say i'm not an
ornament aficionado but
this thing is a perfect combination of
cute and horrifying to freak out your
friends and relatives text christmas to
83 400 to get your tree decorated today
these things are going fast get yours
now you're listening to the largest
fastest growing conservative podcast and
radio show in the nation
[Music]
okay so this monolithic culture war that
is being waged by every institution in
american society
on one side of the particular aisle it
is particularly strong in hollywood
which is a monolithic media culture
right i mean the people in hollywood
are 100 percent on the left except for
people who are underground there are
many many people who are underground i
have met with heads of studios who are
conservatives
we meet in anonymous places wearing
baseball caps to ensure that nobody
recognizes us
because everybody is afraid of what will
happen if god forbid it is found out
that they don't agree
with this overwhelming left culture in
hollywood
well the problem is that the content
that hollywood puts out of course echoes
all of the left's messaging so perfect
example the hollywood reporter today
reporting abc's the rookie is leaning
into calls for a more nuanced approach
of how cops are portrayed we want to
change things for as long as we get to
do this show
when the writing staff of the rookie
remotely reconvened in june they weren't
exactly sure what to do
not only were they setting out to make a
third season of their abc drama during a
pandemic they had to break stories for a
cop show
as countless americans took to the
streets in protest of george floyd's
murder days earlier by minneapolis
police
and of the systemic racism that made his
tragedy all too common by the way i just
got to point out
i'm old enough to remember when the
media used to say things like alleged
murder
right isn't it kind of amazing that the
media just go george floyd murder
i mean really that's actually an issue
that is under contention and will be
under contention at the
at the trial for derek schaben who's the
cop in that particular case but the
media just say george floyd's murder
as though there is no issue under
contention there factually speaking it
just demonstrates that
the media have no actual objective fact
standard
according to executive producer and
writer terence paul winter he says we've
always been aspirational in our
storytelling but we realize being
aspirational isn't good enough
we can't do one special episode where we
feel good and solve racism in the end
and then go back to our usual thing the
next week we want to change things for
as long
as we get to do the show so they have
decided that they are going to
put in a bunch of messages promoted by
the interest group color of change now
color of change is a far left interest
group this is not
unusual for hollywood for many many
years for example the gay and lesbian
alliance against defamation has
pre-screened hollywood shows
to make sure that portrayals of gays and
lesbians don't make gays and lesbians
into villains and also that there are
enough gay and lesbian characters on
particular shows for them to get the
glad stamp of approval so this is not
unusual
color of change apparently is now going
to be doing the same for hollywood shows
the civil rights advocacy non-profit
which has sprawling initiatives pursuing
criminal justice voting rights and
economic reform
is becoming more and more involved in
the entertainment industry in an effort
to help it move away from the unhelpful
narratives audiences see on camera
what we see on tv it impacts the way we
vote the way we react to people even the
way we either believe black lives matter
is a terrorist organization or not
says color of change culture and
entertainment advocacy director kristen
marston who's consulted on more than 100
tv series about issues facing black
americans
these things are so foundationally
important
a hundred different tv shows so now
basically all of these shows are going
to be run by color of change
that is the idea here i mean that's
pretty incredible stuff
color of change has taken several steps
to make it easier for the film and tv
to show up for the black community since
the summer the group partnered with
michael b jordan in june on change
hollywood
an initiative that aims to provide
concrete steps that can be taken by
studios
production companies and agencies to
invest in quote anti-racist
content authentic black stories and
black talent anti-racist content doesn't
mean anti-racism
content it means content that is
designed to tear down the system in true
robin d'angelo or ibramex candy fashion
hollywood is just a propaganda machine
for the values of the left which is why
they cancelled cops
it's why they canceled live pd
it's why they thought about canceling
paw patrol right the fact is that
hollywood is repeating these messages
because there is a monolithic culture
war that is going on all of the
institutions have been taken over by
people
who agree with the left and now it's
going to be crammed down on you from
every possible angle
and this does have real life effects it
does here is one of the real life
effects
so los angeles county district attorney
george gaskin
issued a directive yesterday to
prosecutors he announced
the following misdemeanors in la will be
declined for prosecution
with exemptions trespassing disturbing
the peace
driving without a license prostitution
and resisting arrest
all of those misdemeanors will now be
declined for prosecution so if you
resist arrest
right an officer comes to rescue and you
resist arrest then
this will be declined for prosecution in
l.a prostitution no longer a crime in
l.a
driving without a license is no longer a
crime in la
which is madness i mean that's craziness
disturbing the peace and trespassing so
you just
walk onto somebody's property no problem
anymore
they've decided they're just not going
to enforce these laws anymore why
because we know the police
are bad now simultaneously you'll hear
that the police should be used to track
down
all of you bastards who have been having
family gatherings for thanksgiving and
christmas
we've got to activate the cops to do
that because the cops are great in those
circumstances but you know when they are
enforcing laws against
say trespassing or prostitution
or breach of peace then all of a sudden
the cops are bad again
okay the the culture war is driving more
of the division in the country than
anything else
i know there are a lot of people in
america who want to attribute america's
current divisions to issues of race or
issues of class those are not the
current divisions in america what we
have
is a culture war on our hands what we
have is one culture that suggests that
the other half of the culture is evil
and needs to be extirpated from american
society
there's a reason that the democratic
party has put together an intersectional
coalition
not with white working-class americans
that was historically what democrats
thought they were doing right they were
going to get
impoverished minority members who wanted
more government programs together with
white working-class people who wanted
more government interventionism and that
would be their coalition
and then they discovered in the 1960s
and beyond
they just have they discovered that
instead they were going to aim at
college educated americans so there's
going to be
white woke people who are college
graduates getting together with the
intersectional coalition
and they are going to be fighting
against quote unquote traditional
american values right they're going to
be tearing down the systems in favor of
anti-racist
systems okay that is the battle that is
going on right now
and it motivates nearly everything and
if you are looking for a common theme
to everything from cheering on
authoritarianism from the top of
government
to a culture war that decides that the
police are bad
and that anybody of the right must be
thrown out of the halls of polite
society
that is the common thread that is also
the common threads of the backlash it is
not a racial backlash
and there's this going theory on the
left that the reason for the trump
coalition and the reason the white
working class rebelled
is because the white working class don't
like seeing the intersectional coalition
well that doesn't explain why trump won
an increased percentage of latinos in
blacks in the last election cycle
the answer is not that the answer is a
culture battle is being waged it's being
crammed down on you you can feel it the
number one question i get
every single day from people i'm talking
people in the highest halls of power
i'm talking about athletic stars
everybody ranging from athletic stars to
the heads of major hollywood studios is
i am afraid that if i speak up i'm going
to get fired what do i do
from the most powerful to people who are
just high school students and are afraid
that their friends will never talk to
them again or teachers who are afraid
they're going to get fired
or factory workers who are afraid that
their bosses are going to throw them out
i get these sorts of i probably get
dozens of these questions every single
day
cancel culture is real okay and cancel
culture is ugly
and canceled culture is tied to an
ideology which is that the elitist gets
to decide what is appropriate and what
is not and then they get to cram it down
with the force of government behind them
and the and the culture wars are going
to continue at pace it's going to get
more and more radical because one thing
you have to acknowledge
is that the intersectional coalition
that is pushed by the democrats and when
i say intersectional coalition what i
mean is this
kimberly crenshaw was a theorist a a
basically a critical race theorist who
suggested
something true and then built on that an
entire implausible fiction that has
become
sort of the going concern to the left
the truth was that in america you can be
discriminated against for multiple
reasons so for example you can be
discriminated against as a black woman
in a way that you are not discriminated
against as a black man because you're
discriminated against because you're
both black
and a woman right the intersection of
your identities is the place of
discrimination
okay that is quite possible there's
nothing really wrong or implausible with
that theory
but she then built from that a sort of
postmodern
victimhood hierarchy whereby we can
determine
who is most victimized by the number of
intersectional groups to which they
belong
and then we give those people the most
credit in tearing down the system
those are the people who need to be
listened to and otherwise you should sit
down and you should shut up
right that is the intersectional theory
that has been pushed well the problem is
the intersectional coalition
is filled with victim groups or supposed
victim groups who are constantly pushing
for the next item on their agenda
they're growing more and more radical
over time
right you can see this right every
element of the intersectional democratic
victim group
coalition is pushing for more radical
policy so you have
places like color of change pushing
defund the police and you have the lgbt
movement not just pushing
for leave us alone and let us have gay
marriage but pushing for
religious institutions must be forced
forced into acquiescence with our
policies
right you've got the the transgender
groups pushing for the idea that
men biological men must be allowed into
women's bathrooms right all of these
groups are pushing for whatever is the
next agenda item
and the problem is as those agenda items
grow ever more radical there is a
majority of americans who oppose that
stuff
including many minority members and they
start to push back against it this is
why the left has to win the culture war
it is a battle of life or death for the
intersectional woke coalition
they have to grab those commanding
heights of culture and cram it down
on you and everybody feels it this is
why
these issues matter they do matter to
pretend they don't matter
is to ignore the actual battle that is
happening every day in the lives of
americans
because guess what tax rates matter an
awful lot less than whether you believe
that you're going to be leading
a life of social isolation because all
of your moral betters have decided on
twitter that if you don't use
specifically preferred pronouns this
means you are a bad person not to be
conversed with
this is why it does matter when the
supreme court turns down a case
from a group of parents asking whether
it is a violation of their kids rights
for boys to be allowed in the girls
locker room this does matter those
issues are not
side issues there are core issues
because they go to the question
of whether or not a majority of
americans are still capable of
mobilizing in defense
of their own rights and in defense of
basic truths and basic reason
the goal here is to innervate whether we
are talking about coveted policy
and your acquiescence to shutdowns that
are not rational or whether we are
talking
about ridiculous gender policies that
are being pushed by the left
the goal here is to silence you the goal
is to take a majority and silence it
okay we talked about the silent majority
in the united states trump has talked
about this a lot
the truth is you are the silenced
majority and all the institutions of
culture will be brought to bear in order
to silence you
that is the common thread and the
question is are we going to fight back
or are we not going to fight back
alrighty meanwhile
a couple of stories of corruption that
have been breaking on the scene
so this is a pretty incredible story
well it turns out that uh ilhan omar
right member of the squad ideologue
extraordinaire well it turns out that um
her husband just got a bunch of coveted
19 loans
that um he didn't need according to hot
air
and this is ed morrissey reporting ellen
omar's 2020 campaign paid at the firm
co-owned by her husband
tim mynet over 2.7 million dollars for
services rendered allowing the couple to
keep a significant part of the 5.7
million dollars they raised for her
re-election
and they raised 5.7 million for her
re-election and nearly half of it
went to the firm co-owned by her husband
which is one hell of a grift right there
the e street group llc was by far the
biggest recipients of omar's campaign
accounting for half of all disbursements
the second ranking recipient was the
state democratic party with just under
400 thousand dollars
at the same time that e street group and
mynet omar scored big incomes with the
campaign
they also scored big on covet 19 relief
according to fox news public records now
show that the e street group co-owned by
omar's husband tim minet
received nearly 135 thousand dollars in
paycheck protection program loans
and 500 grand in economic injury
disaster loans
federal election commission filings also
showed the firm received payments for
other campaigns
including 175 grand from the committee
of representative
jayapal of washington and nearly 130
grand from the minnesota democratic
farmer labor party
so why exactly was the e street group
llc in need of taxpayer support
why did a member of congress who
personally benefited from campaign
donations through e-street group
allow her husband's firm access to 635
in subsidized relief loans in the first
place you might think that this should
get the attention of federal prosecutors
i mean it is not a shock that um omar
suddenly announced in mid-november that
should be cutting ties with her
husband's firm
after winning re-election in minnesota's
fifth congressional district
the star tribune noted at the time this
was not a spontaneous demonstration of
transparency
she cut ties because an outside group
had filed a complaint about her campaign
finance ties
the fec according to the star tribune
has taken no public action in response
to a complaint last year
from a conservative group alleging money
from omar's campaign paid to now husband
tim mynet and his e street group llc for
personal
travel expenses the contract was a
lucrative one for e street group
the omar campaign reported paying more
than 1.1 million dollars for advertising
and consulting
in the third quarter of the year alone
this is a grift
omar is obviously corrupt or if she is
not corrupt she best show her cards
because that is about as corrupt
as it looks speaking of corruption
fascinating story from axios today
demonstrating that suspected chinese
intelligence operatives developed
extensive ties with local and national
politicians particularly democrats
who could have predicted such a thing
including a us congressman
axios did a year-long investigation and
what they found was a political
intelligence operation run by china's
main civilian spy agency between 2011
and 2015. apparently while the suspected
operatives activities
appear to have ended during the obama
administration concerns about beijing's
influence operations have spanned
president trump's time in office and
will continue to be a core focus for u.s
counterintelligence during the biden
administration the woman at the center
of the operation
is a chinese national named fang fang or
christine fang she targeted up and
coming local politicians in the bay area
and across the country who had the
potential to make it big on the national
stage
through campaign fundraising extensive
networking personal charisma and
romantic or sexual relationships with at
least
two midwestern mayors feng was able to
gain proximity to political power
according to current and former us
intelligence officials and one former
elected official
even though u.s officials do not believe
that fang receives or passed on
classified information
the case was a big deal because there
was really some really sensitive people
caught up in the intelligence network
according to a current senior u.s
intelligence official again this axios
reporting
on ties between democratic politicians
and a chinese spy
among the most significant targets of
fang's effort was one eric swallow d
farting california fang took part in
fundraising activity for swalwell's 2014
re-election campaign according to a bay
area political operative and a current
u.s intelligence official
swalwell's office was directly aware of
these activities on its behalf the
political operative said
fec records don't indicate fang herself
made donations
but fang did help place at least one
intern in swalwell's office and
interacted with suawell at multiple
events over the course
of several years amid a widening counter
intelligence probe federal investigators
became so alarmed by fang's behavior and
activities that around 2015 they alerted
swelwell to their concerns
giving him what is known as a defensive
briefing apparently swallow immediately
cut off all ties
to fang and feng left the country
unexpectedly in mid-2015
axios concludes the case demonstrates
china's strategy of cultivating
relationships that may take years or
even decades to bear fruit
the ccp the chinese communist party
knows that today's mayors and city
council members are tomorrow's governors
and members of congress beijing has been
engaged
in serious acts of intelligence
gathering and honestly was doing the
kind of stuff that you
that you see in shows like the americans
at least two separate sexual
interactions with elected officials
including one of these midwestern mayors
were caught on fbi electronic
surveillance of fang according to two
intelligence
officials she volunteered for hannah's
unsuccessful 2014 house bid he
eventually ended up
joining the house in 2016.
kana's office said the fbi did not brief
him on her activities
fang helped with a fundraiser for tulsi
gabbard in 2013
she appeared in photos over multiple
years the host of california politicians
including khanna
swalwell representative judy chu of
california and then representative
mike honda democrat of california
choose apparently honda said he had no
memory of meeting fang but
it's pretty obvious that she was
gathering political intelligence china
continues
to be an enemy and apparently they were
targeting people who were
just around joe biden according to a top
u.s official
he told a think tank last week u.s
intelligence has seen a sharp uptick by
the ccp
to influence democrat joe biden's team
and those around him according to
national council intelligence and
security center director william
evannina he told aspen institute that
china has launched an influence campaign
on steroids targeting
biden that is according to ryan svedra
of daily wire
he said i think the last few months
parallel to the elections we've been
dealing really heavily on the kobe 19
front and china's efforts to
thwart that not only in the vaccine but
also in the promulgation of a supply
chain
and the movement of a vaccine all the
way to inoculation but we've also seen
an uptick on influence campaigns to the
new administration
obviously the attempt by china to
influence biden is nothing new
you'll recall that in the middle of the
campaign there was a report that came
out that the media then studiously
ignored suggesting that china was in
fact attempting to influence the
election from outside in favor of joe
biden
remember that evanino released a
statement
in the middle of the year in august
saying we assess that china prefers that
president
trump whom beijing sees is unpredictable
does not win re-election china has been
expanding its influence efforts ahead of
november 2020
to shape the policy environments in the
united states and pressure political
figures it views as opposed to china's
interests
and deflect and counter criticism of
china
so china is engaged in influence
operations and is worthy of keeping an
eye on them especially considering the
kind of nicety with which joe biden has
treated china remember he refused to
label them an opponent
instead joe biden has suggested that
their flourishing would be good for the
world which uh is an arguable
proposition at best just ask the people
of hong kong who now live or
who now live under the tender mercies of
the chinese government
okay meanwhile the media continue to
suggest that we have a crisis of faith
in american democracy
weird because they didn't seem to think
there was a crisis of faith in american
democracy when they spent four years
declaring that president trump was a
russian plan but now eugene robinson is
deeply worried about the future of
american and democracy
he writes in the washington post today
democracy requires faith
president trump and his unscrupulous
enablers including most republican
elected officials
are cynically destroying that faith for
millions of americans i fear the nation
will pay
a terrible price oh um have you yet
acknowledged that stacey abrams is not
governor of georgia have you
acknowledged that the mueller report
turned up absolutely nothing of relevant
interest with regard to
trump russia collusion but eugene
robinson is deeply worried about the
the institutions of our democracy again
the the insane irony of hearing from
democrats who have spent years
undermining fundamental institutions of
american democracy saying that the
senate is bad saying the electoral
college is bad suggesting that trump was
going to burn the mailboxes to stop the
vote
and now they're turning around they're
like well trump won't accept the results
of the election
democracy is in threat no it's not
there's a process and the process is
playing out
but they're hitting the panic button now
jim clyburn
is suggesting that there are some
fragile there are some threats to our
fragile democracy
remember james clyburn is also the sort
of character
who has uh who has suggested in the past
holocaust comparisons i believe he he
compared
i believe republicans to nazis at one
point in the last several weeks here is
jim clyburn
the democratic majority weapon there are
some
genuine threats uh to this fragile
uh democracy of violence we've seen that
play out now for the last
uh four years and it's now being put on
steroids
and so anytime uh this kind of uh
invitation uh that this president
uh is giving to uh people around the
country and
that comes to the floor of the house
it's serious
i don't think it will prevail right so
it's a threat to democracy says jim
clyburn it's all threats to democracy
okay i mean if you're talking about
threats to democracy and the undermining
of faith in public institutions this guy
literally said
i believe the week after the election
that donald trump was like adolf hitler
for refusing to concede
the results of the election uh no
i'm gonna go no on that and then i've
been telling people for a long time now
i'm beginning to see what happened in
germany back in the 1930s
i never thought that could happen in
this country how do you elect a person
president then all of a sudden
give him the authority to be dictator
that's what we're teetering on here
that's what hitler did in germany
meanwhile as far as whether the process
is working the process
is working okay right now there's
apparently one kind of final lawsuit
that is happening in georgia eric
erickson who's been very skeptical
of the lawsuits filed by the trump team
and lynn wood and sydney powell in
places like georgia
he tweeted out this morning about this
case in georgia while i remain skeptical
it is the first case the trump team has
filed that is based on actual voting
data that alleges a number of people
voted who should not have
and that their voting exceeded the
margin of victory they have the names of
the voters etc
they filed the case this past friday
they forgot to pay the filing fee so it
got thrown out
today is the last possible data file i
didn't get a judge reverse certification
of the election but he says this is a
serious credible
lawsuit so that is good news right i
mean that is what you want you want a
serious credible lawsuit you don't want
more
press releases you don't want more
hearings that are public but not
actually legal in intent
what you want if you want to change the
outcome of the election is proof of the
allegations that have been made
and apparently that is now being brought
in a lawsuit in georgia
which is probably a good thing
considering that the so-called kraken
lawsuits were all dismissed
over the course of yesterday hot air
reporting a federal judge swatted down
sydney pal's so-called crack and lawsuit
in michigan
ruling her team never provided evidence
of either fraud or legal errors
a michigan federal judge linda v parker
ruled against her request
from powell to force the state to award
its electoral votes to trump despite joe
biden
winning the state by about 150 000 votes
a 36-page opinion said in fact this
lawsuit seems less to be about achieving
the relief
plaintiffs seek as much of that relief
is beyond the power of this court and
more about the impact of their
allegations
on people's faith in the democratic
process and their trust in our
government
the they don't have any really further
next steps
apparently the the injunctive relief was
denied not only was the injunctive
relief denied there was another lawsuit
that was thrown out the georgia lawsuit
from sydney powell again this is the
kraken
lawsuit was thrown out by a judge who
was a george
w bush appointee the judge said state
courts need to hear those sorts of cases
not federal courts and said the
plaintiffs do not have standing and also
dinged sidney powell
for untimeliness because they could have
challenged this a while back
meanwhile the calls for a special
session of the legislature
in georgia those are going unheeded
mainly because it's not super legal
according against you hot air despite
public castigation by donald trump and
demands from four state senators both
governor brian kemp and lieutenant
governor
jeff duncan announced they would not
call a special session to choose new
presidential electors
under both state and federal law the
legislature is not able to pick new
electors anyway
they say while we understand four
members of the georgia senate are
requesting the convening of a special
session of the general assembly
doing this in order to select a separate
slate of presidential electors is not an
option allowed under state or federal
law
state law is clear the legislature could
only direct an alternative method for
choosing presidential electors if the
election was not able to be held on the
date set by federal law
in the 60s the general assembly decided
georgia's presidential electors
will be determined by the winner of the
state's popular vote any attempt by the
legislature to retroactively change that
process
for the november third election would be
unconstitutional and immediately
enjoined by the courts resulting in a
long legal dispute and no
short-term resolution meanwhile
president trump is trying to do the same
thing with the pennsylvania house
apparently
according to the washington post
president trump called the speaker of
the pennsylvania house of
representatives twice during the past
week
to make an extraordinary request for
help reversing his loss in the state
reflecting a broadening pressure
campaign by the president and his allies
to try to subvert the 2020
election result the calls confirmed by
house speaker brian cutler's office
make pennsylvania the third state where
trump has directly attempted to overturn
a result since he lost
the election allegedly to vice president
joe biden he previously reached out to
republicans in michigan
they didn't do it he tried to pressure
brian kemp to do it that's illegal
and now he's trying to do this with the
republicans in the state house
cutler told the president the
legislature didn't have the power to
overturn overturn
the state's chosen slate of electors
the house speaker was among about 60
republican state lawmakers who sent a
letter to pennsylvania's congressional
representatives urging them to object to
the state's electoral slate on
january 6. that is when congress is set
to formally accept the results
although such a move is highly unlikely
to gain traction at least one
pennsylvania republican said that he
would probably try to do that
so is any of that likely to succeed no
so that georgia lawsuit is where it's at
and they have to file similar lawsuits
that actually allege the harm
that actually evidence the harms alleged
in places like pennsylvania because
remember even if georgia would be
overturned
trump still is behind in arizona and he
is behind in pennsylvania he would need
to win georgia and arizona and
pennsylvania
or reverse the the constituted results
there
in order to overturn the status of the
election in those states right now so
for all those people who are saying
that this is all threats to democracy
it's not a threat to democracy there's a
process the process is moving forward
if team trump is going to show their
proof then now would be the time to do
it in places like georgia as well
as in the other states and there are
allegations out there
right the allegations are out there you
know i talked on this program
yesterday about this tape we've talked a
coup about a week ago there's this tape
that emerged
from fulton county showing people
allegedly
taking boxes of ballots and then
processing them after telling everybody
to essentially clear out of the room and
then i talked on the show
about the claims of the officials
involved who suggested there was nothing
really unusual about this
that the ballots had been there because
everybody knew the ballots were there
they were not hidden that this these
boxes ballots basically
their absentee ballots you have what are
called ballot cutters
the cutters take off the signature
portion of the ballot because
ballots are supposed to be anonymous and
then you process all the ballots after
you box
them up the allegation is that these
were fake ballots or that these were
stacked ballots or something like that
that voter fraud took place the
republican observers were cleared out
and then these were all processed
through the machines the state has said
no normal processes that you take out
those boxes and you process them and
that even if people made the mistake of
leaving
there were state election observers who
were there within an hour of that
happening
and also there were cameras in the room
okay there are outstanding questions to
be asked about that case
whether those ballot it should be fairly
easy to prove if a bunch of ballots
were were put through that were never
registered
that should be if the numbers don't
match up if the number of
registered absentee ballots does not
match up with the with the number
uh the number of signature slips does
not match up with the number of votes
that were actually processed that would
be a pretty easy way of telling if
there's voter fraud
all that stuff is going to have to come
out in the wash
molly hemingway has a good piece over at
the over at the federalists
talking about open questions with regard
to that video
that pieces is worthy of a little bit of
review
she points out that well the state
claims that people were not cleared out
of the room so the state said
people were not cleared out of the room
that never happened there was no
official who said that everybody should
leave
but as molly hemingway points out
georgia republican party chairman david
schafer has consistently said that that
is what happened at state farm arena
beginning hours after the election he
said
2pm november 4th fulton county told our
observers last night to go home because
they were closing up
and then continued to count ballots in
secret that is backed by sworn
affidavits from two republican observers
they further alleged they were kept an
unreasonable distance from the ballots
even while they were at state farm arena
and the video seems to back that up as
well so as molly hemingway says
on the one hand you have sworn
affidavits from missouri observers
saying supervisors told ballot counters
to go home for the evening
shortly after 10 pm and a video showing
everybody leaving at that time on the
other hand you have two government
officials promising no one was told that
counting was over
abc news did report that ballot counters
were sent home at the time republican
observers
said everyone was told counting had
stopped
apparently the election department sent
the ballot counters home at state farm
arena at 10 30 pm according to regina
waller the fulton county public affairs
manager
for elections now the the
sort of debunking of this story focused
in on the idea that a state election
board monitor
said that he was present at the vote
counting location beginning at 11 52 p.m
but that leaves about an hour and 20
minute gap between when the room was
cleared
and when he showed up now does that mean
that voter fraud took place
no not necessarily again it's all on
video and it is unclear on the video
whether
these ballots were there whether they
were not there apparently people who are
in the know
in georgia suggest that the ballots had
been properly tabulated before and put
in the boxes and everybody knew the
boxes were there that's really the key
question here
with that said should all of these
questions be pursued absolutely i assume
that that is the basis
of that of that lawsuit in georgia so
we'll continue to bring you the latest
is that a threat to democracy that
lawsuit in georgia
i don't see why it's a lawsuit and just
like all the other lawsuits will be
processed and it will be gone through
meanwhile there's that pennsylvania case
that is going to probably be elevated to
the supreme court at this point the
pennsylvania case is not
allegations of voter fraud it is
allegations that the pennsylvania state
legislature
had no power to create universal mail-in
balloting back in 2019
because the state constitution requires
an amendment in order to allow that sort
of process
senator ted cruz has announced that if
that does make it to the supreme court
he will argue it in front of the supreme
court is that likely to overturn the
results of the election itself
the remedy is probably not to overturn
the election results but it will speak
to the ways
in which these election processes have
been perverted in order to make it less
clear not more clear who is voting
and how you can hear a lot more about
that story over on the michael knowles
show today
michael's episode is out and available
right now when we wrap here now you head
on over there because he's got the
inside scoop
the man does the show with ted cruz so
he should have the inside scoop
over there all right we'll be back here
later today with two additional hours of
content otherwise
we will see you here tomorrow for much
much more you are listening to the ben
shapiro show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is produced by
colton haas executive producer jeremy
borin
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling
production manager pavel wydowsky our
associate producers are nick sheehan and
rebecca doyle
the show is edited by adam scievent
audio is mixed by mike
coromina hair and makeup is by nico
geneva the ben shapiro show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire 20
20.
hey everybody it's andrew clavin host of
the andrew clavin show you know some
people are depressed because the
american republic is collapsing the end
of days is approaching and the moon is
turned to blood
but on the andrew clavin show that's
where the fun just gets started
so come on over to the andrew clavin
show and laugh your way through the
apocalypse with me
andrew clayton
you